-Action!
-Last year, "Game of
Thrones" set a world record
for the most stunt people
on fire in one shot.
And it looks like it hurt.
A lot.
Can't Hollywood just use CGI?
Each year, dozens of movies and TV shows
feature scenes where stunt performers
are set on fire.
It turns out, this is
often done with real fire,
not visual effects.
Fire and water are some
of the hardest things
to create in CGI.
And stunt performers bring
a unique take to each scene.
-What you still get from a person
that you won't get from VFX
is a human performance and their own take
on something.
-That's stunt coordinator Rowley Irlam.
He's worked on films like
"Guardians of the Galaxy"
and "Harry Potter and
the Deathly Hallows."
His latest project has
been the last four seasons
of "Game of Thrones."
Sounds easy, right?
Get a few stunt people, some fire,
and your scene will look great!
Turns out, even just a few seconds of fire
requires a lot of work.
You're not just setting people on fire,
you have to set them on fire safely.
The most extreme type of burn is one
where the stunt person is
fully engulfed in flame.
But the biggest risk
isn't burning their skin.
-You need to be holding your breath,
so you don't breathe in any kind of flame.
-In order to keep stunt performers safe,
Rowley and his team count out loud
to let them know how much time is left.
-Rowley: 11! 12! Out, out, out!
-They remain on fire
for no more than 15 seconds.
-The danger is disorientation,
or if you were to injure yourself
or bang into something, you know.
What you don't want to do is breathe in
because of a shock of pain or injury.
-Stunt coordinators try to anticipate
and eliminate anything that could go wrong
or cause an injury.
Everything is rehearsed multiple times,
so everyone knows where
to go and what to do.
-If you do enough of it,
you become competent and confident.
We run a very controlled set, you know,
we make a plan, and we stick to the plan,
and we execute the plan.
-In addition to lots of rehearsal,
stunt performers wear a
ton of protective gear.
And their secret ingredient
is a flame-retardant
material called Zel Jel.
For "Game of Thrones,"
stunt performers wear
three layers of fireproof underwear,
which is soaked in Zel Jel.
Above that is a rain
suit to prevent the gel
from being absorbed by the other layers.
Next is a fire suit
and a thin cotton suit.
Any exposed skin is
also coated in Zel Jel.
Finally, their costume goes on top.
-Rowley: You are now
ready to be set on fire.
-And Rowley Irlam is no stranger
to setting people on fire.
For season seven of "Game of Thrones,"
20 stunt performers were
set ablaze at a single time,
and 73 were lit on fire
throughout the course of the scene.
Each performer has their
own safety partner,
who helps them get dressed
and extinguishes their fire.
For every four safety people,
there is an additional safety person.
That's more than 45 crew
members for just one stunt.
It took weeks of pre-production
and multiple cameras to shoot.
But the key to making
that scene convincing
wasn't the fire.
It was the acting.
-What we wanted to do is find the humanity
of the situation.
These are the human moments
when you feel their suffering.
-Crafting a scene that looks realistic
while maintaining strict
safety standards isn't easy.
-Well, the challenging thing is
to make sure that you
don't make a mistake.
If we can get through
stuff and make it look
really, really exciting and dynamic
and not hurt anybody, then we've won.
When we were planning
to do the 20-man burn,
it was going to rain on Monday.
And I was like, "Well, it's sunny now."
And they were like,
"Okay, what do you mean?"
I said, "Well, let's do
this afternoon then."
And he was like, "But we can't!"
And I was like, "Well, why?"
And he went, "I don't know."